So I want to continue talking about this basic
story or sub personality or game or map.
So what I’ve discussed with you so far is
that there are different ways that you can
construe the objects and territories that
you inhabit, and that modern people generally
think that the world they inhabit is one that's
defined by science, but I would say - I would
say actually it depends on which scientist
you mean because I don't believe that the
worldview that emerges as a logical consequence
of Darwinism is the same worldview that emerges
as a logical consequence of Newtonian presuppositions
and you know the reason I’m bringing Newton
into it is because we still think in Newtonian
terms and it’s been more than a hundred
years or about a hundred years I guess, since
Newton’s model was expanded by quantum physics,
but no one thinks that way because you can't
think that way and besides that, the reason
you don't think that way is because at the
level of resolution that you exist, things
behave in a Newtonian manner so it’s in
accordance with some of our natural perceptions.
Now, I started thinking this way for a variety
of reasons but I was influenced later by a
guy named Gibson - JJ Gibson, who wrote a
book called “An Ecological Approach to Visual
Perception.”
And he made the case, quite strongly, that
what you directly perceive is the implication
of situations and objects.
So for example, I suppose you've all seen
the famous visual cliff experiment with babies
where if you put a piece of glass across an
open space and the space is evidently deep,
the baby won’t cross the glass and so there's
some evidence there for relatively innate,
not only depth processing.
It’s not just depth processing, right, because
in order to not crawl off that, you also have
to perceive that - well Gibson would say that
it’s a falling off place, and he would say
that's actually what you perceive is a falling
off place and then maybe you can extract out
the idea of cliff, but that isn't what you
perceive and you know, the sense you have
when a bear is chasing you that’s dangerous,
that doesn't seem to be merely psychological
in a sense like it’s not merely, in a sense,
not - it’s not less real than perceiving
the bear as an object.
An object that eats you is not the same object
as an object that remains neutral to you or
positive, and it seems quite clear, and this
is where the Darwinian issue I think arises,
that you have to evaluate with your perception
because otherwise you're too slow.
So anyways, I developed this diagram as a
consequence of thinking about these things
for a long time, and the diagram is predicated
on the idea that when you begin to act in
the world, you're inside a motivational frame,
let’s say, and that motivational frame can
be instantiated or put into practice or put
into place by any number of underlying motivational
systems, some of them the more basic motivational
systems that we share with animals going far
back down the evolutionary chain and some
of them more complex mixtures of emotional
or motivational drives that been organized
across lengthy periods of times in social
circumstances.
So for example, if you're at a bar and you're
looking for someone, it’s not really reasonable
to say - we’ll take the simple case.
It’s not really reasonable to say that your
behavior is motivated by sex because that's
what happens only if you're actually in a
sexual act.
Before that, the motivations are multiple
and they have to be because otherwise you
wouldn't have the sophistication to begin
a conversation with anyone.
So to think of that as driven in some sense
by sexuality means either to consider a much
more expanded notion of sexuality or to not
consider it driven in that manner.
Now, I think it’s reasonable to make the
presumption that you're motivated to move
ahead and we know that for a variety of reasons.
Partly that’s because if you look at the
brain at the level of the hypothalamus which
is a very, very archaic and primordial subsystem
in the brain, then it’s roughly divided
into two parts and one part is responsible
for a lot of the things we consider basic
motivations, and the other part is responsible
for exploration.
So the dopaminergic tracts whose operation
underlies movement forward and incentive reward
and what you generally experience as the sorts
of positive emotion associated with hope,
and excitement, and curiosity, that system
is instantiated in the hypothalamus, and a
lot of the hypothalamus is devoted to it.
So, as a very primordial system whose operation
appears to be a default.
It’s a default operation if none of the
other motivational systems need current attention.
Well the other default I suppose is sleep
or rest and you can certainly see that in
animals because, you know, if you have a cat
you’ll notice - of course they’re nocturnal,
but they'll sleep a large part of the day
and so do dogs.
So, you know, if you're not looking for a
partner, if you don't want to play, if you're
not hungry, not thirsty, and so on, not under
the grip of any direct biological necessity
let’s say, then your default position is
to rest or sleep or to explore, and the thing
about the exploratory circuit is it’s really
old.
It’s as old as pain.
It’s as old as lust.
It’s as old as anger.
It’s as old as hunger.
It’s as old as thirst.
Like it’s a really, really old system.
It’s a very primordial system, and human
beings are quite hyper exploratory, at least
collectively as you can tell because we keep
inventing new things and exchanging new modes
of being.
So, you can say in some sense that you have
a drive to engage with the world and to expand
your domain of knowledge.
And the reason that you have that is because
the human race has gambled on that as a sufficient
means of ensuring adaptation into the future,
you know, and it’s a strange one because
most animals are very, very conservative.
In fact, most human societies are very, very
conservative so it’s certainly possible
for even relatively modern human societies
- so let’s say those that have arisen in
the last fifty thousand years - to remain
relatively unchanged for periods during that
time of up to ten thousand years.
That seems to be what happened, for example,
with regards to the original inhabitants of
Australia and so it’s statis that’s the
norm, not transformation, and you know, even
societies that we feel were very dynamic like
let’s say Ancient Egypt still there are
indications in the archaeological records
of relatively unchanged customs and practices
for periods that you would count in the thousands.
So, most animals and many societies bet that
just doing the same thing over and over is
gonna do the trick, and human beings - well
that isn't what we’re like man.
God only knows how that originally came about,
you know.
It was the conjunction of many, many processes
and forces, and it would be very, very difficult
to tell a complete causal story, but anyways
here we are.
Now, it’s reasonable to think of us as motivated
to move forward and motivated to explore,
and so that's the fundamental motivation for
engaging with the world apart from anything
that’s a strictly lower level biological.
And while we’re doing that, it’s also
customary for us to look at the world in terms
of its utility, and I would say with human
beings that it’s a very tool based utility
because you know, our brain is part of our
body.
Our brain is adapted to our body and our body
is adapted to our brain.
Obviously they coevolved and so the kind of
brain we have is the sort of brain that a
creature that stands upright and can manipulate
the world has, and we’ll see some evidence
of that later.
But ebcause we’re so handy, we can speak
with our hands and we can manipulate things
with our hands and we can transform things
with our hands and we can tear things apart
and we can hunt and we can plant and there's
an endless number of possibilities for hand
utilization.
The world appears to us arrayed out as tools,
roughly speaking, and a tool would be something
- it’s hard to get the word exactly right
because I like tool because tool implies something
that you can use whereas Gibson would have
talked about - what did he call it?
I can’t remember.
It’ll come to me in a minute.
The word reflects the fact that the world
is presenting itself to you as something you
can use.
Let me just look that up for a second.
That’s very annoying.
Oh well, whatever.
So naturally when you lay out the world, it
lays itself out into things that are going
to be useful for you, things that are going
to get in your way, and then things that have
neither property.
Under most circumstances, the things that
have neither property are the overwhelming
majority, and that's partly how you manage
to process the world in all of its complexity
with your relatively narrow processing capacity.
Most things have no significance, and they
have no significance within this very very
focal frame which is if you remember the hierarchy
diagram, it’s like in that hierarchy diagram,
most of the time you’re operating at the
level of motor interaction with the world.
You’re actually engaged with the world either
through articulation, but forget about that
for now, or you're actually engaged moving
in the world and moving it around and interacting
with it.
It’s as if you're viewing the world through
a series of concentric lenses and those concentric
lenses exclude and then the highest resolution
lens, the one that enables you to focus closest,
is the one that helps you highlight those
few things in the vast perceptual world of
nothingness that seem to be critical for that
particular operation.
So now, you can see that.
I mean the most dramatic example of that - I
was really personally thrilled about Dan Simon’s
gorilla experiments because I’d been thinking
about this for a long time before that experiment
came out and it was the clearest demonstration
I had seen.
I mean, there's a lot of demonstrations like
that now but it was the clearest demonstration
I’d ever seen that indeed most of what you're
perceptual systems do is exclude.
Now what that means - this is the tricky thing
is that what that means is that wrapped up
in what you exclude is the entire - is all
of being, virtually and that's a very tricky
problem because when you're excluding all
of being, in some sense you're setting its
value to zero.
You say, “Well except for those few things
that I’m concentrating on now, everything
else is zero and it’s zero and unchanging.”
And the problem with that is that lots of
times that’s not right.
Now it’s right enough, luckily enough, and
I suppose this is a consequence of evolution
too.
We’re fast enough or slow enough, depending
on how you look at it so that we can assume
constancy across some span of time under some
conditions.
Now, from a philosophical perspective that's
inadequate.
Some of you might have heard of the phrase
“The scandal of induction.”
Well, it’s a pointer to a very profound
philosophical problem and the philosophical
problem is how do you know the same thing
that happened before is going to happen next?
And the answer to that is generally you don't
know, and it’s a very tricky issue to come
to terms with you know.
I think you can think of things as you know,
if you think about a hierarchy of resolution
again.
I think you can think of things as very, rather
predictably, in their unpredictability.
So for example, there's some indication that
protons decay.
But they decay over such a long time frame
that the probability that that’s going to
affect us is virtually zero, and there's other
things that we interact with quite regularly
like the sun that are stable across timeframes
that make it virtually ignorable.
Well I’ll tell you a story about that, and
this is a good story to indicate how everything
is nested in what you ignore.
So, part of this story is fictional, but part
of it isn’t.
So, one time when I was in graduate school
in Quebec, in Montreal, I was typing on my
pre-hard drive computer and it stopped, and
you know computers do that and so what happens
when your computer stops?
Well, the first thing that happens is it depends
on what you're working on.
That’s the critical issue right?
So what happens is that you have a reaction
that's proportionate to the deemed importance
of what it was that you’re working on and
there's going to be an association between
that and deadlines, and there's going to be
an association between that and amount written
that you think you might have lost, and then.
So there's, there's - because what you're
doing is nested in a hierarchy, you know,
I’m writing a sentence to write a paragraph
to write a essay to hand the essay in to fulfill
a requirement of class to graduate, etc. all
the way up the nested hierarchy.
You're going to be upset in proportion to
the upset - or to the cost of this failure
in terms of that entire structure.
So you do a rough estimate eh, because you
don't really know and generally you don't
assume the worst although you might immediately
because that's the sort of situation where
someone will go - they’ll get angry, or
I will anyways.
I’ll pound my first on the - and then I’ll
curse Microsoft usually or whoever happened
to make the computer, and then I’ll remember
I can usually fix computers if there's something
wrong with them and that probably all it needs
to do is to be rebooted and so forth.
And so what happens to begin with is a burst
of emotion and the reason for that is that
the significance of the unexpected event cannot
be easily constrained, and that's because
there's so many things that might gone wrong.
Now, you know, because the worst case scenario
is maybe your computer is dead, and then that’s
a problem for all sorts of reasons we don't
have to go into, and it’s not just a technical
problem right?
It’s also a political, and social, and economic
problem, weirdly enough, because then when
you go buy a computer you have to figure out,
well who’s the manufacturer and where’s
the manufacturing done, and what's a high
quality computer, and it’s like good luck
figuring that out because they change every
month so you just can't keep track of it.
So it opens up a whole rat’s nest, or hornet’s
nest of problems - or a pit of snakes which
is a better way of thinking about it.
Okay so, fine.
So, my computer’s dead so I try to reboot
it.
Doesn't reboot, and so I think I don't know,
maybe it’s burned out or maybe there's something
wrong with the plug.
So I plug a lamp into the same outlet and
I try to turn on the lamp and the lamp doesn't
go on, so then I think aha!
I blew a fuse because this place had fuses
so fine.
So I go to the fuse box, and it’s daytime
so it’s not a problem, and I look at the
fuses and there's nothing wrong with the fuses
and so I think well I’ll go down to the
corner store and get a cigarette because I
smoked at that time, and I’ll think about
it on the way.
So I go outside and all the street lights
are off.
So the whole city’s come to a halt.
I think, oh there’s a power outage.
It’s like yeah there was a power outage,
and here's what happened.
A solar flare emerged from the sun, surfacing.
It was a whopping big one, and a solar flare
like that sends out a wind, essentially, of
charged particles that come zooming towards
the Earth and we’re protected from them
for a variety of reasons, including the fact
that the Earth is magnetic and for complicated
reasons, that helps protect us from cosmic
rays which is really a good thing as far as
I’m concerned.
But now and then those things are so powerful
that they’ll - well here’s an example.
If you have a hydrogen bomb, a big one, and
you detonate it in the middle of North America
in the atmosphere, high up, you’ll wipe
out all the electronics in the entire continent
permanently because what happens is that when
the bomb goes off, there's an electromagnetic
pulse and that produces an electric current
that runs through the wiring, and that'll
be of - very brief obviously but of sufficient
intensity to fry the electronics.
So, well that's what the sun is.
The sun is a massive hydrogen bomb and so
now and then it goes off with the force of,
you know, millions of hydrogen bombs and then
we get the pulse radiating towards us and
then it sets a current in the power grid which
what happened here and takes out the whole
power grid.
That's what happened at that point.
The Quebec power grid was down for awhile,
and it was because - so that’s why my computer
crashed is because the sun wasn't as stable
as I thought it was.
That gives you an example of just how interconnected
things are and how much you're taking for
granted when you make anything invisible.
I would say that part of what happens in a
civilized society - we’ll say a civilized
and productive society - is that there are
rules of conduct in place and there are effective
processes in place so that most of the time
you can rely on things being like they were
yesterday.
So for example, our power supply is unbelievably
reliable given that it’s so intrinsically
unstable.
People have to beetle around nonstop just
to keep the power on, but they do and so we
can sit here and ignore it, and we can concentrate
on something more arcane and much more focused
but it’s also because it’s a relatively
peaceful society and we have relatively peaceful
free speech and so on and so forth, and you
can predict with a high degree of certainty
that if you come to class, then what’s going
to happen in the class - the worst that's
going to happen in the class, likely, is that
you're either going to get bored or hot.
So that’s not so bad you know.
Alright so you're going from point A to point
B, and you see your tools.
I still haven't remembered that damn word.
What the hell is that damn word?
That’s so annoying.
Nope.
Whatever.
You go along and you see these tools.
These are things that are going to help get
you to your goal, and whenever you see those,
you get a burst of positive emotion and basically
that means two things, that positive emotion.
Think about it as a little dopamine kick,
and this is where this story differentiates
a little bit from classic behaviorism.
So the behaviorists would say you get a little
dopamine kick and that increases the probability
that the action that you just took will be
taken again in the future, and so it’s partly
because the dopamine kick has a positive emotional
- it provides a positive emotional experience
but it’s also because the dopamine facilitates
neural growth, and so if you're beetling along
and something good happens to you, then your
brain makes the things you were doing - the
circuits that underlie the things you were
doing just before the good thing happened
- a little bit stronger.
But, the other thing that happens when you're
beetling along and doing your positive thing
is that you get a little dopamine - is that
the fact that it’s working also validates
your frame of reference because you know you
know might say well, if what you're doing
is lurking and you're getting what you want,
how is it that you're right?
And the answer to that is well in some ways,
you're right enough up the entire hierarchy
and so what that means is that every time
you proceed along the path that you've chosen
and that's working, that entire structure
gets stabilized a bit more, and that's how
it should be.
Now, I've tried to work out how exactly this
happens and I can give you the best example
by telling you about cocaine addicts.
So, addicts
use to have this phrase.
“Monkey on my back.”
And that phrase referred to the compulsion,
the compulsive sub personality that develops
that's interested in nothing but more of the
substance.
Now, you know, you think about that as being
hooked and you might think about it as a motivational
drive or a biological drive, but the thing
is it’s not like that.
We’re just not that deterministic.
An addicted person has grown an addicted sub
personality.
And I mean grown.
It’s not psychological.
It’s psychophysiological.
So imagine this.
Imagine this is how it works.
I’ll first tell you what happens to cocaine
addicts if you take them out into a treatment
center.
Heroin addicts is the same thing, roughly
speaking.
So you take this person who’s dependant
out to a treatment center, and with heroin,
say, you have to let them go through withdrawal.
And that takes about forty eight hours, something
like that, and you've seen movie representations
of it, but it’s been compared by reasonable
observers to having a very bad flu.
So, alcohol withdrawal, by the way - that
kills you often.
You have a seizure and you die.
So if you're an alcoholic and you go to the
hospital and you need to detoxify, they'll
give you valium or something like that so
you don't seize yourself to death while you're
withdrawing.
You know, when you have a hangover, part of
that is that - part of what’s happened is
you've actually lowered your seizure threshold.
Something to think about if you're prone to
seizures.
It’s a bad idea to have a hangover.
In fact they bred mice to study hangovers.
They bred mice that could drink alcohol and
then they’d get a very bad hangover, and
if you showed them a cat, they would have
a seizure.
So, because the fear was enough to trigger
seizures.
So yeah, well you gotta get seizures going
somehow if you're gonna study them, and that's
- and that can be bred.
So anyways, you take your heroin addict, let’s
say, and they get over their withdrawal and
so that means that technically they're no
longer physiologically dependant on the drug.
Now that doesn't mean their work is over by
no means.
But frequently the treatment center, as long
as the person is nowhere near where they usually
are, once they’ve gone through withdrawal,
they can stay away from the drug quite effectively,
but the problem is as soon as you put them
back in the situation that they came from,
and they're around the things that have been
associated with heroin, let's say, they get
a craving.
And the cravings haven't gone away.
That's a different system than the system
that went through withdrawal, and so they
always relapse.
Now, you think about how this craving works,
and I've seen this probably most seriously
I guess with cocaine addicts, but also with
alcoholics.
So, imagine what you have to do in order to
become an addict.
You know, the first thing is that you have
to start using the drug.
Okay, but that - and fair enough.
People experiment with all sorts of drugs
and so, you know, that's part of human nature.
You know, it’s risky and dangerous but it’s
not yet catastrophic.
But then let’s say you start using it enough
so that you can't not use it.
You have to use it everyday or something like
that, and then the next thing that happens
is that it gets a little bit expensive, and
so then your life is starting to go downhill
because you're spending all your time trying
to gather resources to get some more of the
drug.
Now, what you might ask yourself is what do
you have - like exactly what’s the chain
of behaviors that's being reinforced by the
drug?
Well somewhere along the way, you know, maybe
when you're just starting to misuse it, there's
part of you that's saying, “You know, really
this is probably not a good idea.”
And then there's another part of you that
has a different thought which might be, “Oh
to hell with it.
It’s only one.
It’s only tonight.”
And so then you take the drug, and then there's
chain leading from the thought to the drug
behavior.
But the drug reinforces all the way back along
that chain.
So what happens is that little system that
thinks, “Oh to hell with it, it’s only
one night,” gets a little stronger.
Now, it doesn't get as strong as the systems
that are being reinforced that are activated
directly before the drug hit, but the thing
is that maybe you take heroin in fifty different
situations and so you're conditioning yourself
to cues in all those different situations.
You use slightly different behaviors and so
on, so there's different things being shaped,
but one of the things that's always being
reinforced, even though not that much, is
this thought pattern, and the thought pattern
is something like “Oh to hell with it, doesn’t
matter anyways” because you have to think
that in order to - especially at the beginning
of a nice downhill trip.
You have to think that, and so what happens
is you build this monster in your head.
It’s full of lies and rationalizations,
and they are whatever lies and rationalizations
allowed you to continue the behavior to begin
with.
But you're making them more and more potent,
and so you build a sub personality inside
of you that it’s a one eyed monster, fundamentally.
All it wants is the drug, and it’s armed
with any number of perfectly, depends on how
smart you are, you know.
You can come up with a very powerful, nihilistic
rational argument why - about why life is
futile and your future is dead and there's
nothing better to do anyways, and you'd be
a fool to engage in such a destructive society,
and etcetera, etcetera.
Like you can conjure up a very - an argument
that’s virtually impermeable to rational
argument.
Rational counterargument.
Because you know, there's some things that
you just can't prove.
Like you can't prove life is intrinsically
worthwhile you know, because for obvious reasons.
So, now the reason I told you that is because
I think it’s a good example of how things
are nested inside of each other you know,
and also the relationship between this very
large nesting of concentric lenses, let’s
say, and the way that those things are shaped
and reinforced across time.
Whenever you're acting locally, and something
goes the way you want it to, let’s say,
and not the way you expect because that's
what Sokolov, and Vinogradova, and Jeffrey
Gray, and the people who were looking at the
orienting response first presumed.
They’d presumed that you wanted things to
go the way you expect, but that's not exactly
right, and it’s an important distinction.
You want things to go the way you want them
to go, and if it’s just expectation then
it’s just a cold, cognitive model of the
world right.
It’s like robotic.
Okay, A happened, now B should happen.
Now C should happen.
It’s like that isn't how you think at all.
You're always inside a motivational frame,
and it isn't only that you expect the next
thing to happen, but if the next thing happens,
it matters whether it’s what you want or
not.
If it’s what you want, then that little
system is reinforced.
It’s pleasurable for you, and then the whole
hierarchy grows a little bit stronger, and
if it is not what you want then you have a
problem.
And that's where things get weird and interesting.
So okay, so you're going along from point
A to point B, and you can see tools and you
can see obstacles, and obstacles are anything
that get in your path.
What that means in some sense is that what
a tool is and what an obstacle is switches
very rapidly as you change focus, and as your
intent changes.
So it’s a dynamic system.
Alright, and so the way emotion works in this
regard is if things are going the way you
want them to then you feel positive emotion
and that keeps you moving towards your goal,
and if you run into an obstacle, then you
feel negative emotion.
Okay so, the next issue might be well just
exactly what should you experience when you
experience negative emotion?
Well you might say well that's a tricky question
because if you encounter an obstacle, that
means that something about your model is wrong
because if it was right, you wouldn't have
encountered that obstacle.
So this is a very interesting way of thinking.
It’s a pragmatic way of thinking because
what it illustrates is that whenever you do
something, you're acting out a theory of truth,
and the theory of truth is the actions that
I’m undertaking at the moment are sufficient
to reach the goal that I’m aiming at, and
so you set up a theory of truth with each
act.
So, you're always struck with the reality
of truth and error or correct and incorrect
because you can't posit that a goal is worth
having, and if there's a path to it that might
be clear or obstructed without also saying
it matters whether you know what you're doing.
Okay, so you hit an obstacle, and that produces
negative emotion.
Now, the problem you have here is that in
principle, the reason you hit that obstacle
could be that there's an error in your nested
model at any level of the model.
So and that's why I told you about the little
story of the sun.
It’s like normally you just turn your computer
on and off because something has happened
that’s local, but now and then your problem
is that the sun isn't as reliable as you might
like it to be.
And so, you're faced with this insanely complex
problem not when things go right because when
things go right, you can just continue ignoring
everything that you’re ignoring, but when
they go wrong, the search space that opens
up before you is just about infinite.
Now, that has real world consequences.
I mean, one of the things that happens when
people develop panic disorder - what seems
to happen is that…
I can tell you the typical story about how
you would develop panic disorder with agoraphobia
cause the two things are somewhat separate.
So generally this happens to - it generally
happens to women.
It generally happens in their forties.
Women are more susceptible to anxiety and
depression, and men are more susceptible to
substance abuse and antisocial behavior.
Figures that something would go wrong right
now doesn't it?
Okay, so now what do I ask myself?
Well, is this relevant.
Is it going to disrupt the class?
Does it mean that there's something wrong
with my computer?
Should I call the help people?
And I’ll say no we’ll ignore it on the
assumption it will continue working, and until
that hypothesis fails then we can ignore it.
Okay so…
So something goes wrong and this search space
opens up in front of you.
Now okay, back to the agoraphobic.
So what happens to her usually is generally
these are people who’ve had dependant relationships
and perhaps they had a relatively overprotective
family, or let’s just say protective family,
and then they had an intimate relationship
early in their life and maybe that lasted
quite a long time or maybe they're just married
to the same guy, but the - and inside that
relationship, she’s relatively dependant
which means probably she doesn't go anywhere
without her husband, you know, she doesn't
do a lot of things autonomously let’s say.
Okay, so then she hits menopause and you know,
she’s getting some strange physiological
symptoms from that of various sorts.
And maybe at the same time, maybe she talks
to her husband about a divorce or maybe he
talks to her about a divorce or maybe her
sister gets divorced or maybe a close friend
dies or maybe she starts to experience heart
palpitations because of the menopause.
And then she thinks, “Oh my god.
That could happen to me.
It’s like my whole world can fall apart.”
So that’s one fear.
“My whole world could fall apart.”
So that's sort of the fear of societal catastrophe
- the collapse of the structure.
And then the other fear is often, “Oh my
god.
I could be dying of a heart attack.”
And so what happens to people who start to
develop panic disorder is that they end up
going to the emergency room all the time to
be checked out by cardiologists, and the cardiologists
are used to this, and they generally check
people up quite extensively but most of the
time if there's something up with your heart,
there's nothing wrong.
But there could be, and so then the sort of…
what happens is the person who is developed
agoraphobia starts thinking perhaps about
what would happen if her husband died or if
they got divorced, and then she starts thinking
about the fact that well she doesn't really
know what she’d do, and she doesn't really
know how to take care of a bunch of things
and how she might take care of the finances
and so forth.
And so, she has no real place to turn, and
so then she makes the fatal mistake.
She goes out and she starts to panic, and
then she goes home.
That's not good.
So if you ever develop severe anxiety, the
one thing you don't want to do is avoid because
of it because as soon as you avoid because
of it, it gets worse, and the reason for that
is imagine her anxiety systems are trying
to figure out how afraid she should be, and
it ranges from panic stricken to none.
Well, the anxiety systems have all sorts of
sources of input because they're trying to
calculate a very difficult problem because,
you know, when this thing flickered, one of
the things that everyone does is look around,
and the reason you do that - it’s called
referencing.
Social referencing.
It’s like, “Well how upset should I be
about this?
What’s going on?” and you look at everyone’s
face and you see well they're upset or they're
not upset and everybody kind of comes to an
average agreement about how upsetting this
is, and we do that very, very rapidly, you
know, and we estimate how anxious we should
be by our default neuroticism, so I would
say generally speaking, if you have higher
levels of negative emotion, rather than lower
levels, what happens is you - the severity
that you estimate a given uncertain event
to exist to have is higher than the severity
someone else might estimate if they were more
emotionally stable.
And then there's another input which is well
roughly how competent do people around you
and you think you are because, you know, how
afraid you should be is actually somewhat
proportionate to how competent you are right?
I mean, if you're a well practiced hunter
and you're out in the forest, and a bear charges
you, it’s like well maybe you’ve seen
a hundred bears and you know what to do and
it’s like it’s a bear and all that, but
you're not gonna run.
And so then the bear probably won't think
you're prey because the bear thinks that if
you run, that you're edible.
Now the thing that's really interesting is
that if you watch yourself run, then your
brain thinks you're edible too.
So that's another input so because - so the
anxiety system is doing this terribly difficult
calibration job which is “Okay something
happened.
How upset should I be?”
Well, how upset are other people?
What’s my physiological response?
How does it compare to other times I was upset.
What are my options?
That's a good one because one of the things
the anxiety systems really wants is that it
wants you to come up with a plan.
It doesn't really care what the plan is although
you have to believe it because it’s not
really a sophisticated cognitive system, it’s
an alarm bell and it says, “Look, something’s
up here.
You have to knit up your world again, and
put it to rest.
We need to be able to ignore everything again,”
and if you can't do that, that thing will
just go off forever.
That’s what happens at least in part to
people who have post traumatic stress disorder.
They're soldiers, you know, and maybe they've
gone out in battle and they've watched themself
do terrible things cause that's actually one
of the most common precedents of post traumatic
stress disorder, and they have no idea how
to represent that in their hierarchical world
model, you know, because part of your world
model, a huge part of it - the “What is”
part, you know, is who you are.
Well it’s like you might find out that you're
not who you think you are.
You aren't even who you think you are a little
tiny bit.
Like there's corners and nooks and whole unexplored
rooms inside of you that contain things that
if they ever come out, you're done.
You don't know what to do with it, you know.
And if you've dealt with something who has
post traumatic stress disorder, it’s very
frequently the case you have to - they have
to learn a philosophy of good and evil in
order to recover.
It has to be sophisticated because they've
seen these terrible, destructive forces at
work and their whole world model is just not
handling it.
So what happens is that the agoraphobic person
runs, and then their anxiety system says well
what's chasing them is obviously a flesh eating
predator, and you know it isn't exactly that
it thinks that although it might have dreams
like that.
They could easily have dreams of being pursued,
but it’s the same system like the system
that we use to run away from things that ate
us when we were thirty pounds is the same
system that we now use to process relatively
abstract threats.
And why wouldn't it be?
Look, as far as I’m concerned, this isn't
even a hypothesis.
It’s like we know evolution is conservative.
Everything builds on what was there before.
So, what else are you gonna use when you're
threatened by some abstract threat except
the system that you used to use when you were
threatened by a crocodile?
So, it’s only…
it’s exactly the way it works.
So then you know, she ends up - question?
Oh no, no you have to run from something.
Just running, that’s irrelevant.
It’s a huge difference.
If you're running towards something, that’s
way different than if you're running away
from something.
Say you’re like anxious about an assignment
and you go for a run and come back more clear
headed to work on it.
You're not running from the assignment.
Are you not?
No, you're just going out for a run, and that's
okay.
Look, let me give you an example.
Well it’s a good question.
Let me give you an example.
If you take a stressor of a certain magnitude
and you are interested in the response of
two groups, if you let one group handle the
stressor voluntarily, and you force the other
group to handle the stressor involuntarily,
the second group will produce much more cortisol
which is the primary stress hormone, and so
voluntary approach - you use different psychophysiological
systems for voluntary approach than you do
for retreat and you know, part of what you're
doing when you're training someone or when
you're using exposure with someone who has
agoraphobia is that you're teaching them that
the voluntary approach system, if you activate
that, that’s a very good way of coping with
anxiety.
Now they don't know that, in this situation
that we’re describing, because they're not
autonomous.
They haven't ever learned to rely on that
system.
So you know, if you're faced with a threat,
there's a variety of things you can do.
You can just panic, but panic is usually distress,
you know.
Maybe a child sort of does that when it starts
crying.
And what happens when the child starts crying?
Well, someone comes to its rescue right.
So one of the things you can do is emit distress
cries and social resources will come and be
gathered around you and maybe that'll solve
the problem.
But that doesn't work when your heart is palpitating
because who’s gonna fix that?
Well often these people...
If you look deeply into their thoughts maybe
they're afraid to ride a subway and the actual
reason they're afraid to ride the subway is
they think, “Well what if the subway gets
stopped between stations and I’m trapped
on here and I have a heart attack and I can't
get to the hospital?”
So that hospital thing is running around in
their head all the time because their default
strategy for dealing with threat is to seek
authority, and one of the things that often
sets people up for developing agoraphobia
is that the authority that they rely on suddenly
becomes uncertain for one reason or another.
Maybe the person is going to leave and they're
isolated or maybe the person, like if it’s
a husband say, the person is - what good is
that?
If your heart’s palpitating and you're gonna
have a heart attack?
It’s a problem that can't be solved that
way.
You know, people might think about that as
a whole existential crisis, and it is an existential
crisis.
It’s like you're coming face to face with
your own mortality, and that's certainly the
case if you're going through menopause at
the same time because that's another, you
know, profound life shift that indicates you're
sort of halfway done, or two-thirds of the
way done.
Something like that.
And that's of course, you know, you can think
about that in terms of terror management as
well.
So it is an existential crisis, and the question
is how do you deal with it?
And the answer to that generally is by becoming
a lot tougher than you are, and the way you
help people do that is teach them there are
certain dangerous situations they can approach
and they can approach them.
And generally, people learn this quite quickly,
you know, and so the psychoanalysts believe
that if you just - this was their early criticisms
of behavioral exposure was that, you know,
if you expose someone who’s afraid, say,
just to an elevator that that will help their
other fears or maybe the fear will be substituted
somewhere else because it’s just symptomatic.
But that didn't work.
It’s not right, and it’s because when
you expose someone to an elevator, you're
not exposing them to an elevator.
If they're afraid of that elevator, you're
exposing them to their own death.
So the elevator, you could say well the reason
behavioral exposure works - and it generalizes
- is because it’s not easy to specify what
the stimulus is.
I mean, when I’m in front of an elevator,
it’s an elevator.
When someone with agoraphobia is in front
of an elevator, it’s not an elevator.
That’s the problem.
If it was just an elevator, they’d just
get on it and away they go.
So you know, I had one client who was afraid
of elevators and the elevator opened up and
she said, “That’s a tomb.”
And it was just an immediate response, you
know, but you could say well that was the
symbolic representation that came to mind,
but you could also say that well there are
similarities between an elevator and a tomb,
and you can get trapped inside an elevator
and you could get trapped inside an elevator
and die in which case it would be a tomb,
and the logical conclusion from that is that
everything could be a tomb.
So you might think, “Well the stimulus isn’t
tomb.”
Like yeah, yeah.
Wrong.
It can be tomb.
It’s unlikely, but then you might also ask
yourself this.
If the chance that you're going to die somewhere
is a hundred thousand to one, should you be
upset?
And well the answer to that is dying is of
infinite magnitude, and if you multiply one
and a hundred thousand by infinite magnitude,
you get a very very large number.
And so one of the things that makes you wonder
is why the hell are people terrified out of
their skin all the time?
That is a very good question because by no
means obvious that people aren’t, and I
actually think - I often think that the mystery
with a condition like agoraphobia isn't that
some people have agoraphobia.
It’s that everyone doesn't have it all the
time.
So because - and you know the terror management
people talk about this too is that because
we’re always confronting our own mortality
and a world of infinite complexity, why aren't
we constantly in a state of panic?
And you know, now and then you realize that.
You think jeez, why aren't we in a state of
panic?
It’s a very unsettling realization, and
why it isn't more common, that’s a very,
very complicated question.
I think a lot of it is that we imitate other
people, and so a lot of our faith, let’s
say, in the stability of our lives and the
utility and the meaning of our lives is actually
instantiated at an embodied level where it’s
not subject to criticism.
So for example, I’ll give you an example.
There's a child two years old and there's
a mother, and they're together in the kitchen,
and a mouse runs across the floor.
Okay, the child orients towards the mouse,
watches it zip across, and then looks at his
mother or her mother.
Why?
Well because something anomalous has occurred,
the significance of which is unstated, and
it’s arousing.
It’s like wow look at that, you know, you
can be startled like that like “Wow look
at that!”
Zip!
Well then you think, what does mum think of
that?
And mum is thinking, “Oh that’s a mouse,”
maybe she’ll tell you about mice or maybe
she’ll set a trap or something.
But she’s calm, and so the child imitates
that, and then you know, they've got this
sense in their body that human beings can
deal with mice and that’s no problem.
The alternative is that the mouse comes up
and the mother jumps up on the table and starts
screaming.
It’s like well, you could be sure what’s
the child gonna do in a situation like that
is burst into tears and be extraordinarily
upset.
So a lot of what we’re doing when we’re
little, and we watch people around us is that
they model being calm.
So we just adopt the implicit assumption - it’s
an embodied assumption - that you can be calm
in these circumstances and luckily enough,
we generally don't - that generally doesn't
come unglued, but you can unglue it even by
deep thought, and that happens to people quite
frequently.
That would be an existential catastrophe.
Alright so, let me show you something else
here.
So, same idea.
Now, this is changed a little bit.
So you're going from point A to point B, and
what can happen?
Well you can encounter tools and you can encounter
obstacles and you can zero almost everything
out.
But you can look at it this way too.
When you're moving forward, you can encounter
what you predict.
That should really be desired rather than
predictiveness in the old diagram, or you
can encounter something that you didn't predict
or desire, and if you encounter something
that you predict and desire, then you have
positive emotion and we know why that is.
You're getting to where you want to go and
it validates the whole structure.
But then, you run into something unpredicted.
Well then, you get - that’s a threat and
you get anxious.
Well you also get exploratory.
So then you might say well, how anxious do
you get and how exploratory do you get, and
I would say it’s proportional - imagine
the hierarchy again.
If you feel that it’s just an inconvenience
that you can make a mild alteration and direct
action and go over, you'll be mildly inconvenienced
and maybe you’ll be a bit curious, but what
happens is that as your suspicion that the
error is occurring at higher and higher and
broader and broader levels in the hierarchy,
the probability that you're going to be anxious,
and quite anxious compared to exploratory
at least initially, starts to mount.
So, and then, all those other factors also
play a role.
You know, your social status, your neuroticism,
your sense of self competence.
How much you've explored all those other things
is a very complicated thing to address, and
so alright.
So then you're going to concentrate on what
happens if you experience an unpredicted outcome
because here's the complicated question.
If you experience an unpredicted outcome,
then you have a weird problem.
The problem is that you have to figure out
what to do about something that you don't
know what to do about, and that’s a big
problem.
So...let’s start with this one.
Alright so, you're going.
You're in the top left hand corner.
You're in this little frame, and you're going
from point A to point B, and you encounter
- I’m calling it now - an anomaly, and anomaly
is something that shouldn't be according to
your model of the world.
Now, what that does is it destabilizes that
model at some level of resolution.
Now what we’re assuming here is that this
is a relatively high order disruption.
Okay so I can give you some examples of that.
The heart palpitation example was a good one
cause that'll kind of unglue you.
Maybe you take your child to the hospital
because they have a minor illness and you
find out that they don't have a minor illness,
they have a major illness, or you find that
out about yourself or you find that about
your partner, or maybe the stock market crashes
or you have a car accident or you write the
MCAT and you end up in the twenty fifth percentile
like the quarter of the people who take it
do, and then all of a sudden bang.
You're not where you thought you were, and
you're not going to where you thought where
you were going and you don't know what the
hell's going on, and that can be as we said,
a small revolution.
You just have to make a detour around it,
or it can just sucker punch you, and that's
as far as I've been able to determine, that's
Alice down the rabbit hole.
That's a descent to the underworld, and what's
down in the underworld?
Well partly what’s down - everything is
down there in the underworld, and the reason
for that...it’s very complicated but part
of the reason is that when things fall apart,
you don't get to ignore things anymore because
you had this model that told you what was
relevant in the world and what wasn't and
the real important part of that model was
that it told you what wasn't relevant, and
then all of a sudden something pops up and
takes you down.
It’s like everything's relevant.
Everything's potentially relevant, and that's
terribly stressful because everything is should
I be angry?
Should I be upset?
Should I cry?
Should I get divorced?
Should I run away?
Should I commit suicide?
It’s like how am I come up with a new plan?
Where am I gonna get money?
Who’s going to help me?
What’s my future going to look like?
What does my past look like?
What am I going to do today?
What am I gonna do tomorrow?
It’s like all of these things come up and
some of that weirdness in the external world,
and that would be well, let’s say that you
discover that your child’s sick, and let's
say the doctors really don't know what to
do about it.
Okay so, you've just been handed a problem
of infinite complexity, and a problem of infinite
complexity is like a journey through a maze
that has no end.
It’s a branching maze, and so what you'll
find yourself doing, for example, is going
on the internet and spending hundreds of hours
- if you've got a research oriented mind - hundreds
of hours looking up every single research
article you can possibly find on this condition,
and that'll range from like the farthest out
new age ideas to the most cutting edge science,
if you can handle that.
So, you know, good luck with that.
That’s an infinite search, and then that's
not the only problem because - so the fact
that it’s an infinite search is very bad
for you because there's no way you can calculate
how much time and energy it’s going to take
you to solve the problem.
So, that’s stressful.
Why?
Well obviously it’s stressful.
It means you have an infinite journey towards
an uncertain goal, and you can't even handle
that you know.
I mean, your journeys have to be such that
they're self sustaining right?
I mean, generally speaking, when you're on
a journey of some sort, you have to obtain
as much matter and energy as the journey costs,
and maybe a bit more because you're storing
some up for the future.
But if you've got this path of infinite complexity
laying out in front of you, it’s like your
body can't calibrate that and so what it does
is it throws you into emergency reaction mode
and emergency reaction mode is prepare for
everything, and that's not good.
And so, down there in the underworld the world
itself turns into a maze of infinite complexity,
but you turn into a mass of competing models,
and a lot of them are based in very low level
motivation.
You're going to be angry.
That’s for sure.
You might be angry god only knows for how
long, you know, if it’s a particularly nasty
disease.
You might be angry for the rest of your life,
and you know, you can be angry in a small
way and accept fate, or you can be so angry
that it completely consumes you and you're
out for revenge against being itself, and
that happens to people, and that's only one
of the emotions and motivational states that
are going to be hyper activated by the response,
and so what happens is that your system collapses
into the underlying basic motivational states
and so you're anxious, and afraid, and angry,
and exploratory, and upset, and all of these
things all at the same time, and that is your
reaction to the unknown.
Your reaction to the unknown is stop, because
you aren't where you thought you were, and
then the next thing is prepare for anything,
and the way you prepare for anything is by
getting ready to do whatever it is that you
can do.
So, I kinda think about it as you’re in
a car and you've got the gas pedal pushed
right to the metal and you've got the break
on at the same time, so the car’s roaring
away but - and you know if you take the foot
off the break, man it’s gonna move, but
your foot isn't off the break because you
don't know where to go but you're still running
at full tilt, and that's not psychological
exactly right.
It’s psychophysiological because you’re
an energy and material burning system, and
if you crank yourself up into high gear then
you're going to be burning a lot more energy
and material, and what happens to people is
that well one of the things that happens is
that you’ll shut your immune system off
because if you're being - because it’s costly
- if you're being chased by a tiger, who the
hell cares if you get the flu in two weeks.
It’s like shut that thing off.
Everything that has to do with long term survival,
even your ability to think into the long term,
is going to be shut off because your ability
to think in the long term failed, and so you
default back down to instantaneous impulsive
modes of actions, and it’s the right thing
to do.
You might think, “Oh well this is a hell
of a time to have a cloudy mind,” but - and
sometimes that's the case - but you're wired
up.
You're trying to solve this impossible problem
which is what the hell do you do when you
don't know what to do, and the only answer
to that is prepare for everything because
you're going to gather some more information
and that might tell you what needs to be done
next but you have no idea how fast it’s
going to have to be done.
It might be like you need to do this right
now or you don't get it don't at all.
So then you're down there in the underworld
where all the, you know, great motivational
beasts lurk and where there's an infinite
path in front of you that's - and maybe you
don't get out, and that's the thing too.
The thing is that this isn't psychological,
and one of the real problems with modern clinical
psychology and modern psychiatry - just conceptually
- is that people automatically assume that
if you have a problem, like if you're depressed
and unhappy and anxious, well then that’s
a mental problem.
It’s a psychological problem.
It’s like it’s a problem insofar as it’s
not pleasant, but what if you're in a horrible
situation?
Well you know, the cognitive people would
say, “Well you know, you just have to reconstrue
it.”
It’s like yeah if you can reconstrue it
man, you're not in a horrible situation, you
know, and one of the things you see with the
cognitive behaviorists for example is when
they assess depression, they use the Beck
Depression Inventory, and I’ve given the
Beck Depression Inventory to hundreds of people,
and their criteria for when you should be
an outpatient in a psychiatric ward is probably
the level of depression that one-third of
you experienced the first year that you were
in university cause I've given this instrument
to lots of university students and one-third
of them, at least in the first year, meet
criteria for hospitalization with the Beck.
So the way that cognitive behaviorist people
- what do you call - evade this issue is that
they just set their diagnostic instrument
so low that the people that they described
as depressed actually don't have a problem,
you know, so I think the cutoff for outpatient
is fifteen.
You know, you're not happy when you get a
fifteen on the Beck, but if you're depressed
you get a sixty.
It’s like you're depressed, and then you
talk to someone like that and you find out
well maybe you're depressed or maybe you just
have a terrible life, and the terrible life
is - and good luck reconstruing that man.
So you're not very bright, for example, and
that's a big problem so maybe you have an
IQ of 85, or maybe you have an IQ of 80.
It’s like good luck finding a job, and if
you do find one, it’s not gonna pay, and
it’s not going to be stable, and you're
not going to get good hours, and so then well
you know your only friend is crazy, and then
your family is like distorted and twisted
up beyond belief so maybe you know, your mother
is chronic alcoholic with dementia.
That’d be a nice touch, and you know, maybe
your friends aren't only not very good for
you, they're actively bad for you because
you've fallen in with some bloody psychopaths,
and because you're not particularly bright,
they can get your money every time you get
your support check, your unemployment check
or something like that.
Well you know, you get someone like that in
your practice and you think, well they're
unhappy.
Are they depressed?
Well, no.
They're in the underworld.
It’s not the same thing.
Here’s depressed.
Depressed is someone comes in.
They're reasonably well educated.
They have a job, and when you ask them about
the job, they say, “Well you know, I used
to like my job” or maybe “I even do like
my job but I just don't find that I'm motivated
right now, and I can't understand why.”
Then you ask them about their marriage and
they say, “Well you know, I have a good
marriage” and then you ask them about their
family and they say, “Well, I’ve got the
average number of family problems but it’s,
you know, all things considered it’s not
too bad.”
And so, and then they don't have a drug or
alcohol problem, but they score like thirty
on the Beck.
You think, “Hey, you can take some antidepressants.
You're depressed.
You don't have a terrible life.”
You know, and they know that.
They often don't have any real cognitive symptoms
either, although they might be reacting more
negatively to some of the negative things
that are happening.
With those people, something’s gone astray,
you know, maybe their sleep is upset.
That’s often the case.
So and what they're suffering from is disequilibrium
of sleep wake rhythms, so it’s gone out
of whack.
So you straighten up their sleep and they're
better, or sometimes they need antidepressants,
but for the first person, like antidepressants
might take the edge off and maybe not too,
but - and what are you gonna do?
You're gonna get the person to reconstrue?
That assumes they have options, you know,
and the problem with educated smart people
is they think everybody has options because
they do.
It’s like no, that’s not right.
Some people have - some people have no options.
They're like trapped in a corner, and no matter
how hard you try, you cannot get them out
of the corner.
Sometimes it takes a virtual miracle before
that can happen.
So the thing about the underworld is that
it’s a real place.
It’s a real place, and - depending of course
on how you define place, but that's exactly
the issue.
How should you define place?
Well, I would say for the sake of argument
that you might as well define it two ways.
You might as well use the standard Newtonian
view, you know, that the world’s made out
of inanimate material entities, arrayed in
a certain manner, because that's a very useful
approach to many problems.
But then there's another perspective which
is no, no, no, the meanings that array themselves
in front of you in the world - those are real.
And you know, I would also say - I’ll just
mention this very briefly.
It’s something the idea I’ve been working
on for a long time is that there’s an implication
of Darwinian theory, and the implication is
that - we talked about this a little bit - the
environment is very complex and it’s transforming
unpredictably, and so what that means is you
can never be right about the environment.
So right, correct is out of reach.
The best you can do is come to partial - you
can partially accommodate it, and so you'd
say okay well how have we partially accommodated
it?
Okay so here we are.
We’ve been evolving for three and a half
billion years, given it our best shot, and
here we have these bodies, and they're out
solution to the problems posed by the transforming
environment, and you might say, “Well how
good a solution are those?”
Well, you've got seventy years.
It’s the best we’ve been able to manage
in three and a half billion years is to generate
up a biological platform that has enough flexibility
to keep up with the environment for about
75 years.
So then you think, so there's no final answer
to the problem the environment presents.
There isn't, and it’s because it actually
changes unpredictably.
So there's no way of being right.
Now then you might say, well what does right
mean?
Well, from the Darwinian perspective, from
some sense there's no other right than that
you're alive and you're likely to reproduce.
That's the best you ever get.
Okay so let’s say that's your pragmatic
definition of right.
Well then what that means is if that is right,
as far as right can be determined, as far
as being human is concerned, then when you
are reacting by fleeing or freezing when something
terrible is chasing you because you perceive
it as a threat, the fact that it’s a threat
is right.
It’s not an overlay on reality.
It’s like if you didn't perceive a predator
as a threat, then you would get eaten, and
so I think - you know, you can think of the
Darwinian world as nested inside the Newtonian
world which is how most scientists think,
but I don't believe that.
I think it’s the other way around.
I think the Darwinian world is the ultimate
world in a sense, and the Newtonian world
is just a tiny subset of that and it’s a
useful subset.
It’s a tool.
It’s useful subset, but the real world - the
Darwin takes precedence over all knowledge
structures.
That’s how it looks to me, and I don't see
a way out of that argument.
So, I mean it depends to a large - Yup.
So are you saying that - cause I’m trying
to understand what you're saying.
Are you saying that like our estimations of
like the deterministic, material world is
nested in an evolutionary drive to find truth
so that we can make quick assumptions about
our environment?
Yeah, so well here's another example.
You guys can think about this for a minute
if you'd like.
So, let’s say that one of the logical consequences
of pursuing science from a Newtonian perspective
is that you learn how to create - cross ebola
with smallpox which is what the KGB was trying
to do in the 1980s.
Okay, so you manage that and everyone dies.
It’s like, how’s that for a validation
of science?
You know, it’s like - because this could
happen right?
Our technological capability which is fostered
by this particular model could easily enable
us to produce something that will wipe all
of us out.
And then well are you gonna say, “Well yeah
apart from that, it was right.”
And then I’d think it’s a tricky argument
because okay let's say - but here's part of
the problem, and I also thought the same thing
about hydrogen bombs.
It’s like well obviously the quantum view,
let’s say, is accurate because if you follow
it you can make a hydrogen bomb.
But then you can step back from that and you
can say yeah, yeah, but to make a hydrogen
bomb or to cross ebola with smallpox, you
have to treat the matter that you're interacting
with as if it’s actually separate from everything
else, and the thing is it’s not actually
separate from everything else.
It’s actually connected to everything else.
Now you can say, well if you treat it as if
it’s separate, here’s some operations
you can undertake.
You can cross ebola with smallpox, but then
you’ve ignored a bunch of things like maybe
that's not a good idea, and then everyone
dies.
And so the reductionism in the model which
helps it specify its target and increase its
accuracy has the corresponding negative consequence
of pretending that the context within which
these enterprises are being conducted can
be ignored and that that’s actually appropriate,
and that's a big problem.
It’s a big problem.
So the evolutionary framework provides the
concepts because it provides like our sense
of morality.
Well, it’s not only because of what it provides
us.
I think the reason that the evolutionary perspective
has to be the one that supersedes is because
you cannot model the environment.
It’s not possible.
All you can do is keep up with it, and the
only way you can keep up with it is through
Darwinian processes - random.
I mean I know it’s not a complete theory,
but for the sake of argument, you have to
generate random alterations, and you know,
you can say well in principle, we can understand
everything scientifically.
It’s like no, in principle, we can't.
Everything's too complex to understand.
So that's why Newtonian physics is nested
within a Darwinian perspective.
That’s right.
Because it’s just an estimation whereas
a Darwinian perspective, it’s like it’s
more in line with what’s actually -
It’s more in line with reality.
Yeah, whereas the Newtonian perspective comes
out of a rough estimation of what reality
is like.
Well Jung, when Jung was talking about the
origin of the scientific mindset, you know,
he traced its development back to alchemy.
Here’s another reason why the scientific
mindset is necessarily nested in the mythological
mindset.
So what the alchemists were trying to do is
mess around with matter and to produce something.
They argued for centuries what this thing
was.
This philosopher’s stone, and what the philosopher’s
stone would enable the holder of it to do
would be to transmute elements into gold,
so that would make you rich, and it would
provide immortality and perfect health for
the person who discovered it.
Okay, now what Jung said - and we’ll talk
about this.
If I have enough energy, we’ll talk about
this two-thirds of the way through class because
it’s so damn complicated that some years
I can't muster up enough energy to discuss
it, but Jung believed that, you know, people
have always been trying to cope with their
mortality, right, and their vulnerability.
Okay, fine, and that makes perfect sense.
So he did an analysis of Western history,
roughly speaking, and said well what happened
- there was a Christian epoch, maybe, that
lasted around 1,600 years, roughly speaking,
and there was an idea at the base of it and
the idea was that through spiritual discipline,
man could transcend suffering, but - the problem
with that was that all this suffering kept
happening, and you know, and there was some
warps in the idea, as Nietzsche pointed out
how this ceasing of suffering was only going
to happen after you die.
Okay fine, then you live forever in bliss,
but still there's like black plague and babies
dying and crops failing, and it’s like it
just doesn't seem that you can just ignore
that, and so you've got 1,500 or 1,600 years
of Christianity, and you know, the whole history
of Christianity behind that grinding away
on this problem trying to produce a system
of redemption, and it doesn't work or it works
partially.
And it also ignores certain things.
So partly what it ignores, you know, one of
the presuppositions of, say, medieval Christianity
is that the world, roughly speaking, is an
evil place, and that matter is corrupt and
unworthy of attention.
Well, one of Jung’s hypothesis is that if
you ignore something long enough, then it
starts to demand your attention, you know.
It’s like a repression, and then that's
especially the case if there's a problem that
you're trying to solve that your current worldview
isn't really solving.
It’s like your attention is going to be
drawn unconsciously to that which you've ignored
and put down, and so Jung saw the development
of alchemy as a parallel to the development
of Christianity, but alchemy studied matter,
which was forbidden in a sense.
It was damned from the Christian perspective.
The alchemists were studying the transmutations
of matter.
They had an intuition that there was information
locked in that.
In matter.
And that if you could just figure out how
to interact with it properly, then you can
free up the information, and they symbolized
that in the dreamlike manner.
The dreamlike manner was you could discover
the philosopher’s stone and that would give
you, you know, wealth, health, and eternal
life.
Well as far as Jung was concerned, that was
a dream, and it was like an artistic production.
It was like the scaffolding of the scientific
perspective because it isn't like people went
from medieval Christianity to full fledged
scientists like overnight.
It took hundreds of years for this to occur.
There were changes in the substrata of thought
that were occurring as this was happening
and Jung traced that back more than 1,600
years in the development of alchemy.
And so, the dream of alchemy was that you
could discover - you could master the transmutations
of matter such that there would be no disease,
that no one would die, and everyone was wealthy.
Well okay that, as far as Jung was concerned,
that provided the motivation for science because
one of the things you might ask is well, why
do people do science.
I mean, most people never have right.
It’s not very old.
Six hundred years.
It only emerged in one place, roughly speaking.
It’s very fragile, and unlikely, and plus
just think of what you have to do if you're
a scientist.
You know, if you're a scientist and you use
a microscope - a high powered microscope - you
have to spend ten thousand hours looking through
that damn thing before you can see what's
there, and so you think that’s a weird thing
for a tree dwelling ape to be doing.
You know what I mean, it’s such a warp of
our natural, of our natural instincts and
our, you know, our desire to make contact
with other people and to be doing something
exciting, and you're looking through this
damn tube, you know, and it’s even painful.
What the hell is motivating you?
And the answer would be, well you think you're
doing something good.
You think that science is going to benefit
mankind.
So it’s nested necessarily in a motivated
system.
It isn't that you do science because you want
to discover facts.
It’s that you do science to discover facts
so that things improve.
Isn't it?
And you just can't ignore the fact that you're
doing it in the hopes that things will improve.
You can't just take that out of the equation
and say, “No I’m purely objective.”
It’s like A, you're not and you better not
be, you know, because a purely objective person
wouldn't be a person.
You couldn't even communicate with someone
like that.
Plus they wouldn't be able to - someone like
that wouldn't be able to determine what was
relevant - distinguish what was relevant and
what wasn't relevant.
You need motivational systems to do that,
and I can tell you.
When you're looking at a data set, there's
an infinite number of things that you can
look at in that data set.
Literally.
I mean there's no end to the statistical procedures
that you can implement.
It’s like fiddling with a photo with Photoshop.
It’s like man, you can fiddle with that
damn thing for the rest of your life, and
so what that means is that the complexity
that’s there can't be dealt with objectively
because if you deal with it objectively, there's
no way of separating the one path through
the data from all the other millions of paths
through the data.
It’s not like when you're doing statistics
man, it’s not like you take a bunch of numbers
and you feed it through the meat grinder and
out comes the results.
It is absolutely nothing like that.
You're making ethical choices at every single
level of the decision, and you know, if you're
- and I teach my students this too.
So I want them to be straight scientists,
and there's lots of things that can warp you
as a scientist, and one can be you want to
have a career, and the other is you want to
climb up the primate, the scientist primate
dominance hierarchy, and you know fair enough.
You need to have a career, and maybe the ambition
is worth it, but the problem with that is
that can make you do things that violate the
principles of the entire enterprise, and that's
happening - I mean it’s been scandalous
particularly in social psychology because
people do what’s called data mining and
they just keep doing their analysis until
something significant pops up and then they
write a story about why that’s important.
I’m not cynical about that.
I understand why it happens.
I think it’s inevitable that it happens
some because lots of people who are publishing,
it’s like the first bloody thing or second
thing they've ever published.
They don't know what they're doing.
There's gonna be error like mad.
But I tell my students, “Look.
If you're going to do statistical analysis
properly, you have to get yourself oriented.
What the hell are you doing?
What is it that you're really doing?”
And you think well I'm trying to discover
something solid, and the reason I’m trying
to do that is because there should be benefits
from that otherwise the whole enterprise is
foolish, and you might as well be a bloody
- you might as well go work in finance if
you're not interested in that because - really,
you're not going to make any money as a scientist
and you can make lots of money in finance,
and you're smart enough to go into finance.
So, if that's what you want - if you want
power and money, and I'm not complaining about
that, it’s like go where it is.
But science isn't it.
If you want to discover facts, maybe, and
that maybe of some benefit at some point,
then you become a scientist.
Okay, so that you gotta keep your eye on the
ball, and then you have to decide if pursuing
that line of truth and benefit supersedes
whatever you might do to build your career.
Okay, cause you're always playing that game.
Always.
Your whole life, and that's actually why so
much of scientific research is wrong.
There's error too, and there's all sorts of
other reasons, and you can't expect a system
to do much better than produce five percent
of useful output anyways.
So, okay and then the other thing is you have
to also be afraid, and here's what you should
be afraid of.
Let’s say that you discover something that
isn't there.
Okay, then you're gonna spend the next fifteen
years studying it.
So if you wanna spend your next fifteen years
studying this thing that you've conjured out
of nothing, then go right ahead.
But if you don't want to do that, then you
better be properly oriented when you do your
statistical analysis, and that's because statistical
analysis is an ethical process, and so is
science because it has to be.
If it isn't nested inside ethics, fundamentally,
then god only knows.
It can be completely destructive.
It could be counterproductive.
Like, so - ah so then there's a variety of
reasons why the Darwinian bucket is sort of
- it’s the outside.
You don't get any farther out than that as
far as I can tell.
So, and it’s the Darwinian world to which
we’re adapted, you know.
That's why we perceive things as threats.
That’s why we perceive things as positive.
That's why we perceive things as negative.
You know, and we tend to think those are overlays
on a deeper reality.
It’s like that is not so clear, and you
know, I didn't know this but when I was working
out these ideas, I had never read anything
that Heidegger had written although his influences
wormed its way into many fields and I undoubtedly
picked up some of his ideas, you know, because
they get embedded in other places, but certainly
one of Heidegger’s claims was that Western
philosophy got off on the wrong foot right
at the beginning because it didn't study being.
It started to think about thought, and what’s
- the real issue is being what is being?
Well being is what you experience, and for
the Heideggerians, that’s reality.
There isn't a reality underneath that.
Now, it requires a real shift in perspective
to start to try to think that way, and I think
the easiest way to do it is to think both
ways, you know.
Sometimes you think like a Newtonian.
Fair enough, and then other times you don't.
And you need to know when to think like a
Newtonian, and when to think like someone
who understands that the phenomena of meaning
that surrounds us are legitimate, and it’s
a very interesting thing, and this is one
of the things that's really driven me through
this material is okay so we can make a case
that like lower order meanings are real.
Like if you perceive a bear or a cliff as
a threat, then that's so you don't die, and
it’s worked really well for things that
have been chased by bears for ever since there's
been bears, and way before that.
But then there’s another question that emerges.
So okay, here’s the question.
So, you've got all these underlying motivational
systems that are built into you as a consequence
of evolutionary processes.
So let’s say it’s your body and the manifestation
of your body in your brain, in your mind.
It’s your basic mammalian wiring, and you've
been working on that ever since we’ve had
nervous systems.
It’s a very long period of time.
That sets you up.
Now you have to add complexity to that, right,
because when you're trying to - because those
systems only have a finite time range so when
you're angry, for example, you're angry right
now and in fact part of a utility of angry
is that it’s right now because it’s a
problem solving mechanism for dealing with
some obstacle that you can't get rid of any
other way than to say, “To hell with the
future,” roughly speaking and deal with
it right now.
Now it’s dangerous, obviously, but it’s
also necessary because otherwise maybe you
get locked into an argument, and you just
stand there arguing for the rest of your life,
you know.
At some point you say, I’m not talking to
you anymore, and the anger does that.
It makes you impulsive and you can walk away.
You know, and sometimes that’s the right
conclusion to an argument.
You know, you're not going to win, and you
don't want to keep arguing so why do you stop?
You get annoyed.
It’s a solution.
You've got all these basic biological systems.
Now obviously, no one of them has the answer,
and you know that because if it did, you wouldn't
need a bunch of them, and you have a whole
bunch of them.
You have pain, and anxiety, and exploration,
and play, and sexuality, and hunger, and thirst,
and you know you can come up with probably
twelve basic emotions and motivational systems.
Okay, so you need all twelve of those in order
to orient yourselves properly in the world
just like you need your five senses, but then
another problem starts to emerge and that
problem is okay, those things have to be regulated
properly, but they have to be regulated across
multiple spans of time, and then they have
to be regulated across multiple different
complexities of social environment.
So you don't just have one system of twelve.
Now, you have a very large number of systems
of twelve for very long spans of time, so
then you think, well out of that emerges a
solution.
We talked about already with the evolution
of games.
Out of that emerges a solution.
You might think about those as higher order
meanings.
So, and you know that, and you do it and you
believe it.
That’s the thing that’s cool.
Here you are in university.
Well you ask yourself why?
You might think, well what do you have to
believe in order to be university?
Well, at some point, your beliefs run out
and you're just here because you've made that
decision.
But I can ask you, you know, why are you in
university?
And most people have about five reasons, and
then they don't know what to say.
So what that means is they have reason A,
and reason B, and reason C, and reason D,
and then they're just acting it out after
that, and if you keep questioning them, they
get perturbed and they'll get annoyed.
Sometimes they'll cry.
Sometimes they'll get angry, like if you're
really going after someone, it’s like what
the hell are you up to and why?
You know, sometimes you have to do that to
untangle something very complex.
At some point, people just - they get angry
or they cry, and that means to hell with you
or you're bullying me, leave me alone, and
that's supposed to get rid of you, you know,
but it doesn't work if you really want to
get down to the answers.
Well, partly what we’re trying to figure
out is why the hell are you in university?
You might say, “Well, to get a job,” but
I might say, “Well why in the world would
that make you satisfied with life?”
Why do you think that would make you satisfied
with life, and you might say, “Well it’s
better than not having a job.”
It’s like yeah yeah fair enough, you know,
like right let’s not forget the practical,
but it isn't the solution.
It’s part of a solution, and the question
is do you really believe there's a solution?
Well you must because you believe it enough
so that you're here, and then you believe
that has something to do with the ability
to think - and you believe that has something
to do with the necessity of understanding
your history and you believe that it has something
to do with the utility of exposing yourself
to what in principle are great rate historical
and literary works.
You assume that that's all valid because even
if it’s implicitly, if it’s implicitly,
it means you're imitating someone who assumes
all that, but either way here you are.
You're doing something, and the questions
is - and maybe this is the critical, I think
this was the critical question of the 20th
century.
Is there any reality to what you are doing,
or is it just arbitrary?
If it’s arbitrary, well you know that's
a path to nihilism because who cares what
you do?
Whatever you do, you're ruined.
You can make a strong case for that, you know.
But the problem with that seems to be nihilism
- try it for a while, you know.
What it produces is misery, and people generally
believe in misery, and they generally believe
that it’s not a good thing to have, and
so I would say nihilism is a self defeating
proposition if you assume that misery is actually
a source of valid information, and you all
do because you know, if someone is jabbing
you with a pen, you're going to move you arm
because you feel that if you can avoid some
misery, that's a good thing.
So you have faith in your experience at that
level.
Well then you might say well you know, if
you can really make a solid case for the believability
for certain kinds of experiences, that they're
real, why can't you make a case for the believability
for higher forms of meaning?
Maybe they're not arbitrary.
We don't know, but I tell you if you act like
they're arbitrary, you get into trouble very,
very rapidly because you either become nihilistic
or halfway down the trip to nihilism, you
adopt some horrible ideology and then you
know, you're possessed by it, and then you're
well - then you're not going to live your
own life because you're going to live the
life of the ideology and you're going to be
dangerous to everyone around you and also
impervious to any sort of reasonable communication.
So if those are the two consequences of making
the presumption of arbitrary meaning at a
higher order level, then to me, they've invalidated
themselves already.
We’ve already had that experiment.
It didn't work.
And so then the question is well what's next?
Well that’s partly what we’re trying to
figure out right now.